yeah welcome to a new 15 minute game
playing against two bak from Denmark let
some see if I can try out some of my
lines that I'm doing in the book thief
we got 493 here against the news oh yeah
yeah i'm actually not decided yet what
what to do this is one of the lines i
was considering attacking c3 here and
yeah this is Sam
one possible answer I can also play
Bishop b2 and now this is the way it
continues b.tech c and 95 yeah man
sometimes there are tricks like we
should be too so he can it's not
mandatory to always mandatory to to take
okay so now I'm it's a bit complicated
his queen is detect and I have protected
his Bishop ever detect espana with the
bishop so he cannot play something like
weenie for I just takes you three he
pretty much has to go to see to keeping
the pawn defended and now I must retreat
Dallas no no alternative one advantage
some of this some line compared to some
others is that I managed to damage the
pole structure without giving up the
dark squared bishop the dark squared
bishop of course is very important here
as it covers the the dark squares like
d6 that our weekend so i can take see
for now or not why is it impossible to
take it I don't know hmm
I don't see it at the moment of course
the winning this point doesn't mean I
win the game but um still okay I don't
see it i take it and hope for the best
fit okay so rock do you one and one idea
is to play four on d5 so that if i try
to try to cover the night he's got some
ideas the thing is should I play a six
so that i can cover the night with
quincy seven without being harassed by
night be five I like this move but Queen
a for I think I was Queen a for Queen a
for I can I even have b5 him night be
596 and then I take it maybe it's not
clear
yeah still I think I need to play the
smooth anyway at some point on queen bee
three Idol Quincy seven this is this is
fine okay he just tries to improve the
position step by step Group B 1 so just
castle him
my text b7 I could try I could try to
defend it with Quincy 7
Group F form I maybe have even if I've
it looks it looks dangerous but probably
I can play it yeah why not why not
defend it for one more move quite often
you simply return the porn on b7 and
just argue okay you got the porn back
but my c8 Bishop was a complete dummy
and your g2 Bishop is is excellent so I
paid the price of a pawn and of course
I'm black is already a porn app so i can
easily return b seven but i don't see at
the moment why exactly i should do that
but it doesn't feel doesn't feel esses
airy to do that at the moment so Queen a
4 ICU it's not be 54 thread if I castle
and I go Quincy five does he do does he
have anything dangerous don't see it I
really don't see it 95 Quincy five look
so it looks okay okay come on don't be
afraid of ghosts it's possible that that
he's got something of course he's active
yeah Quincy five but what what is why
it's big moves after Quincy five I don't
understand anything here help the thing
is if I go here what exactly is he
playing he cannot detect the Queens
Bishop e3 oh I three there's the night
on c4 and I'm threatening yeah a thought
I was threatening Luke Knight b6 with
the tempo and then then just capture
this piece what is this big idea he
played this very quickly also Knight b6
Bishop e3 also loses okay show me I
don't see it
Queen a 5 I take five I cover the rook
so that i can take take the take the
night I don't even see a queen move why
does the Queen go yeah i take p 5 and
then what what what resides on
you
I have this all covered wait yeah just
just blundered basically with the route
before I think I know if I look at this
I mean okay the computer already gives
me close to winning advantage the
problem is this not be five fits with it
if he just needs to return now to avoid
material loss then this was simply
nonsense and I'd be five yeah and he
loses material now I need to go 94 so um
if I look at this you must play
something else but maybe there isn't
there isn't anything great I thought
Bishop f4 this would be interesting d 60
this is a cool knight c6 is a cool move
by the computer this actually looks like
and why it has got something computer
assessment is 000 great but I will and
after this cig at night f5 okay this
looks like like something probably this
moves when I cannot take cause of this
trick and now we need to take care about
those pieces yeah it's very complicated
the computer likes black a lot but it's
a it's not not clear computer move this
bill should be three
if I take everything off here it's this
bad no let's see i probably will get get
material back i can i can take here for
example and of course he will get
something back but I'm already two
points up and half and have damaged
structure even if I return both porns
that should be should be ok yeah this is
one of the lines that I'm considering
for the book against this g3 another
three line but there are many the black
and play yeah thanks for watching